next up Mirror's Edge catalyst we got to
see some gameplay of that one in action
and it's not the whitewashed red
highlighted world necessarily the sort
of city seems to have been fleshed out
aesthetically yeah actually running a
new story when when this was on so I
didn't as you get to see it so I always
could describe it for you just described
it to for everyone well why don't you
look at this trailer now alright well
better yet yeah why don't you see the
kind of cues that are you know the scuff
marks the red walls that are sort of
visual cues to help you maintain your
speed that thing that made mirrors edge
so I like it make it you able to have
that kind of momentum through the world
of course we see some combat with faith
kicking some ass later on but uh the
woman presenting made mention that faith
doesn't use guns yeah and so I doesn't
like use them but she use them image
that you could individually you could
but you also i think you were you were
rewarded if you did like a pacifist
playthrough and didn't use them at all
so didn't arresting do you think they'll
be you'll be able to use them or is it's
just gonna go pure punchy kicky this
time around maybe she just hasn't
learned how to use them yet cuz you
can't you know just pick up a gun and
just or look anybody they are doing that
slash and burn on the story this there
was a lot of different if you've played
the first Mirror's Edge I won't say
anything for spoilers but there are a
lot of small moments in this trailer
that sort of indicated to me that we're
getting a new look at the story I think
I reboot on the story you like that you
like getting a reboot I think it seems
smart yeah yeah um let's talk a little
bit by the fact that it is now
completely open yeah there are no levels
there's it's just complete free roam no
loading screens whoa like wow that's the
real I mean that's really incredible
right so you think about sort of an open
world right and then okay but then how
do you sort of gate players progress
because there's always some kind of
mechanic whether the enemies in a
certain area are just too formidable or
whether you need to get to a certain
story beat to unlock this area so you
can imagine that it's just because it's
an open world doesn't mean you can go
everywhere right from the start but it
certainly implies a kind of freedom yeah
and broad sort of
what's the word that you know like
options in terms of what you can
approach a given situation I'm sorry
that was what the dream of the original
game at least right you wanted that
level of freedom and I think it's really
commendable the EA are trying their best
and rebooting this franchise I think a
lot of people love the original Mirror's
Edge didn't kind of fell short a little
bit in terms of critical response and
sales but so I think they're doing a
great job in just trying to restore it I
think it's gone yeah keeping the visual
identity and sort of the the aesthetic
identity uh but then also giving nods
that yeah this is a new take on mirrors
edge for a new generation of consoles
that's Mirror's Edge catalyst showing
off the e a press conference here at e3
2015